[Música]
y llegamos a venezuela vamos a hablar
con nuestra red de corresponsales ahí
está daniela zambrano porque el gobierno
de nicolás maduro dijo que ofertará en
bolsa el 10 por ciento de algunas
empresas estatales algunas
nacionalizadas por el fallecido
presidente hugo chávez daniela muy buena
mañana de viernes de que empresas
estamos hablando y en qué consistiría
esta privatización y también cómo va a
funcionar
fabol un gusto en saludarte hasta el
momento no hay una lista oficial de
todas las empresas que se van a ofertar
lo que se conoce es lo que dijo nicolás
maduro a través de la televisora del
estado que se ofertaría entre el 5 y 10
por ciento de las acciones de empresas
estatales que como decías algunas habían
sido nacionalizadas por ejemplo la cantv
que hasta 2007 cotizaba en la bolsa pero
posteriormente fue estatizada ahora
volvería otra vez a ser ofertada se
conoce también que estaría en otras
empresas en telecomunicaciones como
movilnet y empresas relacionadas con la
petroquímica también con las industrias
de guayana el sector minero pero como te
digo no hay una lista oficial llama la
atención esta decisión que ha tomado la
administración de nicolás maduros pues
va en contra de que todo lo que había
sido el proyecto al fallecido presidente
hugo chávez que por el contrario
se expropió y confiscó un sinnúmero de
empresas según la ong se dice libertad
hasta 2020 durante el gobierno de hugo
chávez y hasta 2020 más de
5500 empresas fueron tomadas por el
estado confiscadas y por lo menos en el
sector de este agroindustrial sólo el 3%
de ellas fueron para así es daniela un
proyecto económico que como dice la
evidencia y como lo estamos viendo pues
es totalmente fracasado le pregunto
ahora qué reacciones hay en el país es
el anuncio del presidente nicolás maduro
la más reciente ha sido la de la bolsa
de valores de caracas lo ha calificado
como muy positivo pues era una solicitud
que se venía haciendo ya desde hace
varios años sin embargo economistas
coinciden en que estas empresas debieron
haber sido mejoradas antes de ser
ofertadas para que fueran atractivas al
capital internacional muchas de estas
empresas que estamos hablando se
encuentran en franco deterioro sobre
todo el tema de las telecomunicaciones
en venezuela son empresas que prestan el
servicio bastante deficitario sin
embargo lo califican como positivos
otros economistas por ejemplo el
diputado jose guerra decía que esto es
una muestra más de que fracasó ese
proyecto de estatización del gobierno y
que era una forma de enterrar el
socialismo del siglo 21 y otra forma de
admitir que no estaban siendo
productivas estas tres empresas a manos
del estado y la conclusión es
simplemente que el gobierno necesita
dinero necesita de esa inversión y ese
capital porque no lo tiene para mantener
la infraestructura de estas empresas y
para conseguir inversiones también en
estas industrias en esta materia